Yeah. Come on. Don't,
don't Hendricks please.
I wanted a, I wanted one of those fringe
jackets when I was in high school,
so I played football until I was a senior
and then when once football season's
over I have a half a year
left of school and uh,
that's why I smoked
weed for the first time.
You started playing guitar and
I want to want a fringe jackets.
I didn't have one, but I did get a
pair of moccasins for a little while.
I wore moccasins. Did they have
beads? They did not have beads,
but they had the little French too
little tassels. They were like,
it was just a little fringe. Yeah. No
soul. What's the purpose of fringe like?
That's like when you think
of a trapper jacket, right.
When I'm Deann Davy
Crockett type dudes style.
Give him wearing that style's really,
yeah.
Why would they have any style back then?
Everybody's got style back then.
It seems like they were just trying
to stay alive. Yeah, the weak ones,
but the cool ones are
still trying to get laid.
I think Daniel Moon wasn't
trying to work it a little bit.
We'll at this buckskins are
often trimmed with a fringe,
originally a functional detail to allow
the garment to shed rain and to drive
faster. One wet because the fringe asses
a series of wix to disperse the water or
quills. Interesting. Oh Wow.
Buckskins derived from peers can clothing
worn by native Americans. Oh Wow.
How about that? That's
genius. Smarter than you now.
So it hangs down and the
water goes through all the
tissue in the deer and gets
to the bottom. So those little things get
wet. But the thing that you're wearing,
the touches your skin is dry.
You would think by now the deer would
have had fringe on their outfits.
I think the don't give a fuck you or
really hot or their body temperatures much
higher than ours. Oh really? Yeah. It's
one of the weirder things about, um,
when you put your hands on one
inside of them, the really hot,
like if you're for like 98 degrees, what
are they like? I don't know. I would,
if I had to guess, I'd say it's more than
a hundred. Oh yeah, I'd say that. Yeah.
I bet they're probably like 105,
something like that. What? What does it,
which is, what's the body temperature? It
brought up the cooking temperature. Oh,
it's 350 degrees.
They're cooking before we even catch them.
That's hilarious.
That's why people love deer. You
don't have to cook them. Precooked
they're preheated same as most.
It switches 37.5 38.5 degrees Celsius,
which,
which we don't understand this
type in pre heated dear me,
38.5 degrees Celsius. When you
think that is, if you had to guess,
I don't have a clue. What,
what was the, what was the
number 38 degrees Celsius? Oh,
that's 105 is it?
No,
it's like 90 99.5 to a hundred. Right.
In that same range as they are like us,
one or two higher. They're like
someone with a little bit of fever. Oh,
I did something that you would, you would
enjoy. You might have even done this.
Speaking of body heat. Uh, I was
in San Francisco last weekend,
brilliant performing. And uh, I
was working with my friend, uh,
Qras Sultana Bitch, very
funny comedian. She kicks ass,
she's Russian.
She grew up up there and she brought me
to a Russian like bathhouse beat you up
the sticks. Yeah. Do you ever do
that? They call it Banya. Banya man.
Oh Man. You go into a sauna, a two
level sauna. So it's even hotter,
like up at the, at the top, like
an attic in a sauna. Super Hot.
And you lay down on this bench and they
take these bushes like these sticks and
they were, they wet them and then
they start beating you with them.
Not a lot of pressure.
It's too, it's so hot. It,
you're in a sauna, you're
already like, really? Really?
And then that thing just things hot
too and that thing's hot. And with the,
with the steam coming off of the branches,
as they're beating your back,
it creates a little,
a little pocket that gets even hotter.
So it just brings your body to the super
high temperatures they're making and
making whether they really
are anyway and uh, yeah.
For about 15 minutes and you come out of
there and just feel to jump in the cold
afterwards. Yeah. Into a cold plunge all
the way under this really cold water.
Amazing.
Yeah.
The Russians really looked up fade
or a million inco was like one of the
greatest heavyweights, if not the
greatest heavyweight of all time.
One of the things that you'd
see about his training,
what does it was that it was
very old school. Russian,
like a lot of stuff on the
parking or in a, um, a playground,
just like they did a lot of
stuff in a playground and um,
he incorporated the Banya
that was a part of it.
And like you see him lying there
and beaten and what sticks.
There you go see it on time.
So yeah, that's what, yeah,
they figured something out. You know,
all the pretty great invented sauna.
They figured something out.
There's something about that
extreme temperature that just,
it's very good for your, your ability
to recuperate. You feel better?
It reduces inflammation. I felt
great. Like I went in there.
I've been traveling so hard over the
last couple of months have just been
knotted up. I've just
been like, I was like,
maybe I'll do this and
then get a massage after.
Cause that'll really a gentleman. He
like a gentleman and we didn't have time.
She had to go. She was driving
me. She had to go do something.
So we only had time for that part.
When I came out of the,
the Banya or Banya,
I didn't need a massage.
Everything was relaxed. Everything had
changed in just like 15 minutes. Yeah,
it was great, man. I wish it
was a, I don't know if there's,
they have them in la or not,
but I'd like to seek them out.
They know they have them in New York.
One in West Hollywood.
There is photos spot or something
like that. Yeah, there you go bro.
A lot of dongs keep your pants on. A
lot of dogs. Clothing was optional.
Hey, clothing optional, and I'm with
Keira. You know, we're like, you know,
we're coworkers and she's wearing
nothing. She's has, she's totally naked.
And then there's dogs everywhere.
There's dogs everywhere. He's the dunks.
She sees the dogs. I see
that a girl. We're the old.
We were the only ones covered up.
Where were they going? Dong skip.
Staring America. What's that? In America.
You can't do this. Yeah, San Francisco.
Are you sure? Yeah. Girls who's walking
around with dogs. They were naked.
The girls were naked.
He ran.
I are the only ones with clothes on
because we worked with each other.
Sending immigration
police send alert. Yeah. There's
something going on there bro.
It's just dicks everywhere.
Open that door is you.
You cool with Dicks in front of
you? I'm not. I was looking here.
I was looking away. Cops just come in
fucking masks on [inaudible] alert. Yeah,
they throw one of those. What are those?
Uh, gas canisters that flash bangs.
Just grabbing guys by their dogs.
Pulling them out until the paddy wagon.
It would all run out. Grab
them there. Dot. That's the
first thing you got to grab.
Someone throws a tear gas canister.
It explodes in a room cover.
I'm wearing pants.
So I was the only one with pants on and
you can kind of feel like everyone was
looking at you like you're making us feel
like shamed cause you're wearing pants,
man.
It's just take them off.